what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a clip from
fresh and fit when she wants monogamy
what she wants in monogamy isn't what
you expect it's a clip with britney
runner in it before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
as you guys already know if you've
watched two of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef
beef you can't be
taking this content and not supporting
your girl
just help me out please okay and second
off as you guys know
i am trying to save up for a sound board
i have girls on my team they're
international girls from germany japan
all different places around the world
and i want to bring them in and have
them on a podcast here
and talk to them about different red
pill topics but i can't do that unless i
have the sound board it's 500
um i have 150 so far if you donate
i'm gonna like share your account on my
channel or something i'll i'll shout you
out on all my platforms okay
bye-bye
you have to understand like for me i'm
just a different type of person like i
honestly can see all different points of
view and can be like you know what that
does make sense or you know what i never
thought about it like that but i think
for me it's like okay well you know what
i can respect that and i may not agree
with it but that just doesn't work for
me and i think of course you could look
from that standpoint like hey you know
move your ego i think when
it's it's more i think if there was more
transparency like hey you know like you
know you're gonna have this this and
this but i am gonna it's gonna be more
of an open relationship or you know i
want you at home you can't really do
anything or or i want but let me finish
or if it's like i want to be able to
have three steps or i want to [ __ ] you
with another man i just feel like
there's there was a conversation that
could have been had to where let me and
this is the one okay i don't i don't
have a lot of sympathy for brittany
runner
but what i'm talking about is the idea
of
one-sided monogamy
if you're not up front about it how is a
girl supposed to agree to that so how
are you going to say oh you should know
what you're signing up for which
on one end like kind of yeah you know
nba players duh but
but
he wasn't up front with her and there's
many girls he could have been upfront
with and would have agreed to it because
they get all this free [ __ ] that comes
with it and they get the lifestyle
so a lot of girls look the other way or
don't care
but
i don't know it's like if you're not up
front about it
it's not really fair to the girl because
she didn't agree to that and you're
taking her youth to be honest and her
time and she doesn't even know she's
signing up for that make the choice
myself but you took that that that
choice away from me when you decided to
be deceitful and it's like of course you
could assume because he's an nba player
because he's young but at the same time
like if i'm not doing it and in my mind
like you said we're wired so differently
yeah i'm not discrediting that but i'm a
very devoted person so i'm assuming that
you know i'm not wasting my time i'm in
this for the long haul i want to get
married we want more kids like that was
something we wanted to go back to back
on you know so it's like i'm thinking
we're on the same page and i'm like well
where do other women come into the
equation of this relationship so i guess
i think if there was more hey you know
what i am tired of your [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
tired of hitting from the same uh like i
i'm you know i'm ready for something
different like i want i want to see you
eat a [ __ ] i want to see you take a
dick i feel like at that point in time
it could have been like we can work
something out but when you try to be
sneaky and you lie and you doing
whatever and you're not even really
taking care of what you need to take
care of because you're just here's the
money here's the rent here's the card
he's the car i'm emotionally checked out
because you have to understand too we as
women we can feel when you're not really
in it so i just personally am like what
does that mean you're emotionally
checked out
he's probably just sick of fighting to
be honest can you imagine that
relationship that just doesn't work for
me and that's okay like there will be a
woman that would be that would be like
[ __ ] you're so dumb i literally would
have sat there and just wait as i got
the ring do you guys think she's a gold
digger because she did leave a situation
where she would have gotten more money
but at the same time she did make a
video
on how to be a gold digger basically so
i can have more kids with him and just
been in the house with with my credit
card swipe swipe swipe do whatever
that's just not me because i've always
gotten it on my own when you like i i
didn't have a sugar daddy i didn't have
a rich family there was there was no
help here so i think for me when you get
it out the mud and you're step by step
building [ __ ] by yourself you do look at
for me personally i can't speak for all
of us i do look at men differently
because it's like
i can do everything i've bought the
shoes i've bought the bags i thought i
got this car was going to make me happy
but it's the connection i want i can't
buy the connection so let me say this
real quick
what is what is connection ladies
connection's gonna come and go and
that's that's the thing that we need to
accept and it's hard to accept but if
you're married to someone let's say you
get married at 30 and you're with them
until you're 80.
that's 50 years
50.
you don't think the connection's gonna
come and go at some point because you
mentioned a bunch of things there and
the the biggest thing to understand is
that men and women are different so like
i get we were saying like
he took it away from me he didn't have
that conversation that's why women
really need to listen to our podcast
because we tell women all the time if
you're dealing with a guy of a certain
caliber assume he's gonna [ __ ] other
[ __ ]
most guys are we tell guys on our part
all the time yo be honest tell her it's
gonna be open but you know what they're
not gonna do it and the reason why is
because most women
like i said before have egos and think
i'm special i'm a princess i'm the only
one give me that commitment et cetera a
lot of women suffer from princess
dynamics which they think their [ __ ] is
the best and they're special and i'm
here to tell y'all women i don't think
it's
that you're i don't like saying that but
i don't think it's like you're it's the
best it's like
i
if that's the person you pick to spend
the rest of your life with
and you're gonna continue to deceive
them like day by day by day by day
and hide all this stuff from them like
other girls it's gonna catch up to you
at some point
you really think if you're with a girl
from 30 to 80 same thing
that she's never gonna find anything if
you cheat because you
cheaters don't just do it once the best
predictor of future behavior is past
behavior
and
i don't want to say once a cheater
always a cheater but once the cheater
most likely always a cheater
so i don't know not my thing but y'all
are not [ __ ] special you guys look at
you guys
listen
let him finish this point and then i'll
answer women like y'all are really not
that special bro like guys once guys
reach a certain caliber and they're
dealing with attractive women all the
time like beauty is extremely common and
i need women to understand that you are
not that special okay but here's the
thing this is the funny part about this
when i was on his podcast i said what
percent of women would you say our wife
material today he said five percent
you don't think that five percent is
special myron
if it's you you only find five out of a
hundred [ __ ]
you humble yourself and realize i'm not
that special and he can replace me
anytime now you need to have other
redeeming facts that's going to make him
come to you outside of just the sex and
most guys are not going to have that
conversation which you say listen baby
girl i want to have sex with other girls
you might you're just going to have to
accept that it's gonna come with the
territory and assume it's gonna happen
and be open to it maybe hey listen man
do you wanna have sex with other girls
whatever and then open it up and let him
kind of come to you but like a lot of
girls make the card a mistake and think
this guy's a one percenter i'm gonna
have them all to myself but just not how
things operate with not my dad is
i don't care how many people say that my
dad cheats on my mom i don't care all of
you guys are wrong
my dad is literally
one percent guy in terms of income
he is the most loyal dedicated father
that i've i could talk for hours about
how much i love my dad he
literally doesn't drink he doesn't have
social media he's in the top half
percent of earners like you have to
realize some of those guys that are that
rich it's just not worth it to them
like
i've like had this conversation with my
dad
and
he's like women are just problems
like
he
ellie is that oh my gosh my dog is being
so annoying the last couple days
um
yeah i don't know
but it's not interesting
i will say if you do date a guy of that
caliber like your odds are higher of
getting cheated on for sure but that's
why it shouldn't be about money it's
about character it's about who you are
as a person it's not about
money
like
they're
people in hollywood have all the money
and looks in the world and they're
miserable man man they want new box they
want new [ __ ] every guy's gonna tell
you i want some new business the best
thing ever is just that most guys can't
be honest with women because most women
are how do i say hard one not hardwired
society teaches women that they're
special okay i
i know that men
have like the desire for new women
constantly just like women have we have
this natural desire for hypergamy does
that mean
if i marry someone and have a kid with
them and i think i can do better i
should leave
no
but i don't know i'm all for like work
out your relationship do what you guys
want but
if you cheat on someone and you don't
let them know up front like it's that
type of relationship i think you're
i don't think you're a very good person
to be honest
sorry
and they deserve like you're gonna
you're gonna cheat on the one person
that you love more than anyone you're
gonna lie to the one person the mother
of your kids sorry
i don't i don't and that guy's gonna be
committed to them which is a huge lie we
tell women the more successful the man
the less likely he's gonna be monogamous
to you sexually he's gonna [ __ ] other
[ __ ] but he's gonna come to you and i
tell girls all the time yo if you got a
one percent guy hold on to him if he
[ __ ] these other [ __ ] that's fine
he's gonna come home to you that's all
that matters so first i mean i'll just
say this one last thing when he says one
percent he just needs money right or is
it more than that
i would try to work it out with him man
if if i was the girl i would try to work
out and that's that's the father of your
child like cheating that's nothing any
guy that you deal with especially at
your level now no real talk sounds crazy
that sounds crazy but yo brittany i'm
telling you you're at a point
real talk it's not that big a deal bro
like yo i'll cover them a culture where
we have four wives like yo brittany i'm
telling you you're at a socioeconomic
level now and you're at a at a certain
status
like you're at a certain status and a
socio-economic level where the average
guy is no lo you cannot deal with a
regular guy no more you have to deal
with an entertainer somebody has money
an investor something whatever it is
like you're gonna have to deal with a
guy that makes a certain amount of money
and these guys are going to go out and
step out and [ __ ] other chicks anyway
so you might as well accept it from the
father of your child than some other
random dude that is probably going to
have a point of contention with your
past anyway deal with the devil you know
than the one you don't exactly what do
you think about that though because
because by the way i we haven't ever
seen you pop out
you know obviously we've never seen you
pop out with no one since him but we
haven't seen you pop out with a regular
joe schmoe works at walmart he's
clocking in overtime like a [ __ ]
i mean i dated a lawyer does that count
come on man he's probably nearly clocked
in six figures
what do you even consider like a good
amount of money
i would say it depends on your age
i think a good amount of money at 25 is
like
60 i think that's a good amount of money
at 30 maybe 80 right
[Music]
like
you got to be a millionaire bare minimum
probably like you mean like the like
average person like what can you no no
or what you
long term
yeah like if you're with a guy and
you're gonna tell your family like yo he
makes good money what's good money
for you
i mean i feel like anything over a
hundred thousand would be considered
good money wouldn't it
i think that's yeah i mean i don't think
it needs to be like 100 million i think
that's kind of excessive all i want to
say is this cheating is not that like as
women say oh my god he would have [ __ ]
another [ __ ] it's cheating for amy okay
you're putting your wife's health at
risk you can give her an std you could
still give her hpv
i don't know not my thing y'all go crazy
in the streets not not my thing man is
not the same as cheating for a woman if
you guys cheat it's a problem it's a
huge problem because a woman has to get
to a certain emotional point to cheat on
a man but a man does not have to get to
that same emotional point to have sex
with another chick because you can still
love your girl the same and go have sex
with other women it does not work the
other way around though that's why
cheating with from women is i do think
that
cheating is different for men and women
i agree with that
i think you can still love someone and
cheat on them
yeah but
it just makes me think you're not a good
you know person to be honest
unforgivable but from a guy it ain't
that big a deal man like if that's what
it was
now that i know that it was just
cheating i'm like i'm just listening you
better go call him right now how much i
say yeah
but that's why i ask a question why did
it ultimately end because think about
this right like he said earlier you can
go find another guy but i guarantee you
leaves you that's a certain level he's
probably gonna do it too my question is
are you gonna be okay with it internally
and probably not okay can i finish cuz
like don't be like you had an epiphany
about the phone like make a phone call
no
the reality is is like
i would be open to
some different stuff and
as i've like been thinking about i'm
like i think it would be you can't be
sexually promiscuous though
that's but let me finish but i'm saying
like if i got with the guy
who like let's say he wanted to [ __ ]
with another guy i would be open to that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa come on oh my god no guys gonna
agree to that none
none no guy worth anything
99 of men are not going to accept that
they're not going to accept them
well i'm just saying
what's everyone
like that i forgot to mention
he's going to be open and you're going
to be closed
most guys are gonna want you to be close
on your side and he's gonna be open on
his and you gotta accept that okay yeah
yeah
okay but anyway no but seriously though
um i just you know that same footage
last time
i stayed on your system
no not yet
[Music]
i think you know he watches what you say
and i think
you want to just kind of jab him because
you're always going like you have a kid
with him you'll always be a physical
representation of him and what
that's interesting oh
something that [ __ ] hates is when his
baby mama's up there wow her train and
wow yeah wildland no honestly i like i
want monogamy but the reality is is i'm
also open-minded like i'm never gonna
like i have had threesomes before with
like different girls and [ __ ] but like i
mean i've definitely never been with two
guys at the same time don't do it
everybody wants that yo you should do
the three some of the two goes with you
no no no no no no no listen no but my
thing is is i just
like nobody yo if y'all if if we say
let's us two with her
if you say you wanna wife her i'm gonna
clown you bro yeah if i know that a girl
has been with two guys i can never it's
a rap wife never gonna get wife bro i
don't care what you've got baptized i
don't give a [ __ ] no normal guy is ever
gonna share his girl especially his wife
a woman that he takes seriously with
another dude most guys are not gonna do
that yeah no that's
no no no no weirdos will so it's like
like i said damn you gotta accept a
couple things you're that sweetie [ __ ]
right now you said that last night
[Music]
yo the moment quavo heard that he was
out the belly came back so sorry about
what if you met a guy right what if you
met a guy perfect guy tall successful
handsome
you know what britney
i [ __ ] with you
we connect on a deeper level i got you
but
i want to [ __ ] other girls
yes or no
and he's honest from the jump from the
jump you say you know what we do some
things together i got you
it's what it is yes or no gives you keys
to the [ __ ] wraith and you could call
it the private jet what you want
don't add all that in there because that
that's not the selling point i feel like
it's more so it's more so the honestly
yeah that's that's what she's saying
like let
that's the problem though people
you i think you're gonna have a hard
time finding girls that agree to that to
be honest
but maybe not if you're rich i mean look
at melania trump and like basically
every politician's wife okay okay okay
okay
okay
but i feel like
connection honesty is there but it's
like i've never practiced anything other
than monogamy so that's the only reason
why there's hesitation in my answer
because it's like well
i
feel like i mean i do have a competitive
spirit you guys are being too nice it
doesn't [ __ ] your feelings it doesn't
matter because you know real talk i just
got to keep it real yo the caliber of
men that you deal with you have no
leverage with them brittany because
here's the reality i got to break it
down for her
i got to be honest like yo you're at a
level now where most men can't compete
to even for you to even see them as a
viable option so the men that you
actually do see there's a lot of young
beautiful girls and they don't care
about how much money she makes however
you are looking for a very small
demographic of man that has to hit a
bunch of things on a checklist and
you're competing with a million other
bimbos on instagram only fans etc that
are attractive that can get these this
man's attention so you don't have the
same leverage to get these kinds of guys
they have all the leverage and i always
say it the more success you have as a
woman the more money you make you
inadvertently give leverage to the man
because now the man is the commander
because you're fighting after a small
group of men but you could also just
date an average guy
my problem is i'm above average in
height i think that
hurts me more than anything to be honest
oh my gosh you're fighting to get him if
i was five five i don't know why you
five five girls need the six four men if
i was five five i would be cool with
like five seven and up to be honest you
can't date down he can though so we
could say what do you think about this
hypothetically i'm here to tell you you
have no stake in the game [ __ ]
interesting
that was fun that was a fun video um oh
shoot
it's an interesting conversation you
definitely get
more of that with like entertainers
and musicians for sure um but guys
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time